Traduttore: Alessandra Santagati
Revisore: Eleonora Cavallo
Grazie.
È un grande privilegio essere portavoce
della nostra scoperta scientifica.
Infatti abbiamo intercettato
per la prima volta
un'onda gravitazionale
che attraversava la Terra.
In questo speech spero di potervi dare
un'idea dell'importanza di tale risultato.
Tutto parte...
(Si interrompe per riformulare)
Tutto parte, ovviamente,
dall'esplorazione dell'Universo.
Questa è la fotografia del cielo stellato
nell'emisfero australe,
la Via Lattea domina il cielo stellato.
Sicuramente è una meravigliosa fotografia.
È stata ispirazione ed è
soprattutto oggetto di indagine
da moltissimo tempo.
Ma nonostante tutti i nostri progressi
e tutta la nostra scienza,
purtroppo, ad oggi, conosciamo
soltanto un ventesimo
di ciò di cui è fatto l'Universo.
Un 5 per cento abbastanza insoddisfacente.
E la restante parte, il 95 per cento?
Si tratta di materia oscura.
Sappiamo che esiste perché ne vediamo
l'attrazione gravitazionale
sulla materia che noi conosciamo.
Però è materia che non corrisponde
a nessuna caratteristica
della materia che noi conosciamo.
Si tratta di energia oscura.
È una forma di energia
distribuita nello spazio,
che è necessaria per spiegare
come mai osserviamo che lo spazio
si sta espandendo in accelerazione.
Questo potrebbe essere,
è una proprietà dello spazio vuoto,
che però finora è sfuggita
alla nostra indagine.
Queste sono grandissime questioni
ancora aperte, tutte da indagare.
Noi abbiamo allungato la nostra vista
sulla luce dell'Universo,
costruendo meravigliosi telescopi
sia a terra che nello spazio.
Quella piccola macchia rossa
nell'ingrandimento è, in particolare,
la galassia più lontana mai osservata.
È stata osservata a marzo.
Ed è così distante
che la luce della sua immagine
ha impiegato più di 13 miliardi di anni
per raggiungerci.
E ci ha regalato questa fotografia,
che è stata praticamente scattata
400 milioni di anni dopo il Big Bang,
in un'epoca in cui l'Universo
era molto giovane
ed era giovanissima questa galassia,
probabilmente di un paio
di centinaia di milioni di anni,
per una galassia è un tempo corto.
Abbiamo esteso la nostra capacità
di osservazione oltre la luce visibile,
a una vasta gamma di frequenze
dello spettro elettromagnetico.
Qui abbiamo varie mappe del cielo,
che mostrano il cielo
come si vede in onde radio,
come si vede in microonde,
come si vede in infrarosso
e come si vede in raggi gamma.
Ciascuna di queste mappe porta
un'informazione particolare,
diversa dalle altre,
qualche caratteristica dell'Universo
che si mostra in queste mappe.
In particolare, possiamo prendere
ad esempio la mappa del cielo a microonde:
la mappa del cielo a microonde è
in realtà la testimonianza del Big Bang
maggiore che noi abbiamo,
perché da essa possiamo capire
le proprietà della radiazione fossile,
che è stata liberata solo
380 mila anni dopo il Big Bang.
Ma non ci siamo accontentati di questo.
Negli ultimi anni e decenni,
abbiamo costruito rivelatori
anche per catturare le particelle
di origine cosmica che colpivano la Terra.
Qui abbiamo solo due esempi:
abbiamo, a sinistra,
un edificio in Antartide,
l'edificio di controllo
di un enorme rivelatore,
che in realtà è immerso
nei ghiacci dell'Antartide.
Un rivelatore che caccia neutrini.
Invece, a destra, abbiamo un'immagine
della International Space Station --
la Stazione Spaziale Internazionale --
che, fra gli altri esperimenti,
ospita un rivelatore
per misurare la composizione
dei raggi cosmici,
di materia e antimateria
nei raggi cosmici.
Tuttavia, tutto questo enorme sforzo
non era ancora abbastanza,
mancava un tassello fondamentale,
perché è la gravità
che domina l'evoluzione dell'Universo,
è la gravità che determina
la struttura dell'Universo che conosciamo.
E quindi ci serviva un sensor,
un altro sensore
che fosse in grado di trascinare a noi
l'informazione sui campi gravitazionali,
su come si modificano
i campi gravitazionali lontano da noi.
Ebbene, un ricevitore
di onde gravitazionali.
Einstein, un secolo fa, ci ha insegnato
che la gravità domina il tempo,
controlla il ritmo di ogni fenomeno.
Infatti, possiamo immaginare
per esempio uno spazio
e di essere spettatori di un concerto,
lontano da una grande massa,
quindi come se fossimo
in una stazione spaziale interplanetaria.
Immaginiamo di ascoltare e di essere
lì presenti a questo bel concerto
e immaginiamo di confrontare
questa esperienza con un concerto gemello,
che invece avviene e viene trasmesso
vicino alla grande massa.
Ora, quello che succede è
che da questo confronto ricaviamo
che il concerto vicino alla grande massa
viene rallentato dalla gravità,
la grande massa rallenta il tempo,
rallenta il concerto,
come qualunque fenomeno naturale:
è una legge universale.
Stessa cosa sulle distanze, sullo spazio.
Noi sappiamo che la gravità
curva e piega le traiettorie,
è un'esperienza di secoli.
Però, ragionandoci su, quello che succede
è che Einstein ci ha dimostrato il modo
in cui la gravità piega le traiettorie.
Immaginiamo di lanciare da A' a B'
lo stesso oggetto
che avevamo lanciato da A a B.
Da A a B, lontano dalla massa,
la traiettoria è praticamente rettilinea.
Se andiamo più vicino alla grande massa,
quando lanciamo l'oggetto,
la traiettoria si piega.
Il modo in cui si piegano
queste traiettorie è talmente universale
che è possibile descriverlo come
una proprietà dello spazio stesso,
come una variazione
delle distanze dello spazio.
Quindi possiamo dire, grazie a Einstein,
che è lo spazio che si curva
per la presenza delle masse,
per la gravità.
Quindi possiamo dire
che la gravità forgia lo spazio-tempo,
determina la struttura
dello spazio-tempo in cui viviamo.
Ci sono voluti decenni però,
dopo l'intuizione iniziale di Einstein,
per convincere la comunità
di fisici teorici prima,
e poi tutti gli altri scienziati,
che le sue predizioni erano
effettivamente molto ben fondate.
In particolare, aveva fatto
due predizioni estreme:
la possibilità che ci potesse essere
una massa talmente concentrata
da impedire a qualunque cosa
di uscire, di scappare, di fuggire.
Questi li abbiamo chiamati
buchi neri negli anni '60.
Quello che si vede è questa superficie,
che ovviamente è
una visualizzazione artistica,
ed è una superficie scura
perché niente può fuggire da essa,
neppure la luce.
Noi perdiamo ogni informazione
che sia caduta dentro il buco nero.
Un'altra grande predizione
che costò diversi decenni,
prima di riuscire a essere condivisa,
fu quella delle onde gravitazionali.
In pratica, immaginiamo due stelle,
due grandi masse che orbitano
molto velocemente una intorno all'altra.
Muovendosi così velocemente, il fremito
che provocano alla curvatura dello spazio
in realtà è tale
da poter emettere un'onda,
una vibrazione che si propaga
alla velocità della luce,
allontanandosi dalla sorgente.
Le qualità di queste onde
sono particolarmente strane,
nel senso che interagiscono
così poco con quello che trovano,
che praticamente sono inarrestabili.
Ed è sicuramente un linguaggio del cosmo
che prima ci era impedito di conoscere.
Cosa succede quando
un'onda gravitazionale raggiunge la Terra?
Per fortuna siamo lontani dalla sorgente,
perciò si può fare un calcolo più facile.
Ma in realtà immaginate
quel tubo che vedete
e che l'onda gravitazionale
venga attraverso l'asse del tubo.
L'onda gravitazionale,
deformando lo spazio
e cambiando le distanze,
ovalizza continuamente il tubo.
Quindi deforma qualunque
corpo sia immerso nello spazio,
potremmo dire che deforma lo spazio,
in un modo direttamente proporzionale
alla distanza che stiamo osservando.
Quindi più osserviamo in grande,
più la deformazione sarà grande;
se osserviamo in piccolo,
la deformazione sarà piccola.
Questo effetto, però,
è estremamente minuscolo.
È questo il problema:
lo spostamento è qualcosa come
10^(-18) metri su ogni km,
non più grande di quello.
Questo vuol dire che tentiamo di misurare
un miliardesimo di miliardesimo di metro.
Questa era la sfida:
costruire rivelatori --
ci abbiamo messo mezzo secolo per farlo --
che fossero in grado di trovare
uno spostamento di corpi,
una variazione di distanze
che fosse corrispondente
a un miliardesimo della dimensione
di un atomo su un km.
Abbiamo visto tanti tentativi
che i fisici hanno fatto negli anni.
Io, in particolare, ho dedicato
la mia giovinezza a un rivelatore a Padova
che è qui rappresentato
con i miei colleghi di quel tempo.
Questo rivelatore non ha portato successo,
nel senso che non è riuscito
ad arrivare alla sensibilità necessaria.
Ma come tutto in scienza,
un insuccesso rispetto al fine ultimo
in realtà non è infruttuoso,
perché ti permette di partire
da una nuova base e costruire cose nuove.
La tecnologia che si è rivelata vincente,
invece, è stata sviluppata negli anni '90
ed è quella basata sugli interferometri:
un rivelatore praticamente
fatto di luce e di specchi.
C'è una luce laser molto ampia,
che viene sparata dentro un fascio,
viene divisa in due fasci:
un fascio va a colpire uno specchio
e un fascio l'altro specchio.
È praticamente un sistema di telemetria,
cioè misuriamo la distanza
di questi specchi distanti.
Misuriamo semplicemente
guardando la luce che torna indietro.
Questo è il rivelatore VIRGO,
costruito tra Pisa e Pontedera --
è una collaborazione internazionale --
che ha già funzionato
e adesso è in fase finale di upgrade,
di miglioramento della sua sensibilità.
È fatto di questi specchi
a 3 km di distanza,
in fondo a quei due bracci a 90 gradi
che potete vedere nella foto.
Cosa c'è dentro
questi lunghi cunicoli azzurri?
C'è quello che è mostrato
in cima alla foto: c'è un tubo.
Un tubo pieno di vuoto.
Noi vogliamo che in quel tubo ci sia
solo la luce, possibilmente nient'altro,
per non disturbare la misurazione.
Poi la luce arriva in fondo ai 3 km
e rimbalza su specchi,
che sono invece nella figura
al centro in basso.
Sono specchi molto grandi,
estremamente sofisticati.
Questi specchi sono
molto complicati da costruire
e sono collegati
a un sistema molto complesso,
perché devono essere trascinati
dall'onda gravitazionale,
ma non disturbati dagli effetti grossi
di vibrazione del terreno, acustica, ecc.,
che l'attività umana
porta nel suo svolgersi.
Quindi c'è un sacco
di tecnologia in questi rivelatori.
Ma un rivelatore non basta,
ci vuole la collaborazione internazionale.
Questo è un punto cruciale.
Ogni rivelatore ha un suo rumore.
In questo rumore non riesci
a distinguere i caratteri gentili
di qualcosa che viene dal cosmo.
Per riuscire a distinguere che qualcosa
dal cosmo è entrato nei tuoi rivelatori,
devi poterlo vedere consistentemente
in più siti, in più osservatori.
E quindi è stata costruita
una rete internazionale,
siamo un migliaio
di scienziati grosso modo.
In particolare i due rivelatori americani
LIGO, a Hanford e Livingston,
erano operativi nel settembre scorso,
mentre VIRGO era ancora in fase
di miglioramento delle sue prestazioni.
Cosa successe di magico quel 14 settembre?
Era notte, per fortuna.
Questi complessi rivelatori erano
ancora in una fase di messa a punto,
come un enorme organo che dovesse
essere accordato prima del concerto
e il concerto era previsto
per qualche giorno dopo.
Per fortuna era notte,
i rivelatori americani erano in funzione,
senza essere disturbati
dai nostri test di verifica.
L'onda arriva, colpisce prima Livingston
dando un piccolo segnale,
pochi cicli su e giù
nell'uscita del rivelatore.
Notate che la durata di questo segnale
è poco più di un decimo di secondo,
una sillaba.
Dopo 7 millisecondi
l'onda colpisce Hanford
e mostra nel rivelatore
una forma molto analoga.
Infatti, la cosa fondamentale,
che ci riempie anche di gioia,
è che il nostro programma automatico
di riconoscimento dei segnali
capì subito, in 3 minuti,
che si trattava di un segnale consistente,
qualcosa che difficilmente si poteva
spiegare con un disturbo nei rivelatori.
E quindi subito la domanda:
è questa la prima sillaba
dell'onda gravitazionale?
Partì subito un'attività frenetica,
che durò 5 mesi.
Prima di tutto, lanciammo l'allarme
in modo da poter dire:
"Per favore non continuate l'accordatura
degli strumenti, così com'è va bene,
dobbiamo studiare
come stanno funzionando in questo momento,
per non disturbare
le loro caratteristiche".
Secondo, abbiamo mandato
un allarme ai partner astronomici,
perché se hai visto
un'onda gravitazionale,
devi cercare se c'è
una sorgente elettromagnetica
che si è accesa
contemporaneamente nel cielo.
Ma la cosa più difficile per noi
sono stati i cinque mesi di verifiche.
Verifiche molto meticolose
che abbiamo affrontato
per poter essere sicuri e poter difendere
la nostra affermazione
di aver visto per la prima volta
un evento cosmico raggiungere la Terra.
Sono state verifiche meticolose,
si dovevano escludere molte possibilità.
Queste verifiche che sono state svolte
in un clima di riservatezza.
Noi non abbiamo comunicato
al mondo la nostra scoperta
se non l'11 febbraio, 5 mesi dopo.
Questo perché ci vuole libertà di critica,
ci vuole un confronto aspro e duro,
di idee, non di personalità,
per riuscire a fare
un buon lavoro scientifico.
Quindi la collaborazione si è chiusa
e si è cominciato a discutere:
noi facevamo la parte
dell'avvocato difensore
e un sacco di gente
faceva l'avvocato del diavolo,
per uccidere il segnale.
Ma alla fine il segnale è diventato
effettivamente indistruttibile.
Dopo un secolo di sviluppo teorico
e mezzo secolo di sviluppo strumentale,
finalmente abbiamo un'interpretazione
della prima sillaba di questo linguaggio,
un'onda gravitazionale
che raggiunge la Terra.
Si trattava dell'ultima danza,
l'ultimo giro di orbita di due buchi neri.
Due buchi neri grossi
30 volte circa la massa del nostro Sole.
Orbitando perdono
l'ultima energia a disposizione
e poi collidono e si fondono
in un buco nero finale,
grande una sessantina di volte
la massa del nostro Sole.
Questi oggetti sono molto piccoli,
circa un centinaio di km di raggio,
quindi hanno una grande massa
in poco spazio.
La scoperta è rivoluzionaria
per tre motivi fondamentali:
uno, perché è la prima registrazione
diretta di buchi neri.
Cioè prima non potevamo
osservarli direttamente,
perché il buco nero non si può vedere:
niente esce dal buco nero,
tranne la vibrazione nello spazio-tempo
che il suo orizzonte degli eventi,
che il suo bordo, crea.
Quindi questo è il primo messaggio.
Sì, prima eravamo convinti
dell'esistenza dei buchi neri,
perché vedevamo la materia cadere
dentro un'area molto piccola dello spazio.
Questa è un'osservazione diretta,
che è molto diverso, è più importante.
Poi questo è stato l'evento più violento
che abbiamo mai registrato in astrofisica.
Pensate che ben tre masse solari
sono state convertite in energia,
in un decimo di secondo.
Questo è un evento di estrema violenza.
L'ultima cosa, ma molto importante,
è che questo ha dato la conferma
che la teoria che usiamo
per interpretare questo linguaggio,
che è stata sviluppata
sulla base della teoria di Einstein,
è ancora valida, effettivamente
funziona anche in questo regime
in cui nessun fisico e nessun astronomo
l'aveva mai provata prima.
E quindi è un buon passo
di partenza per un futuro,
perché possiamo effettivamente decifrare
i futuri messaggi che ci arrivano,
sulla base delle competenze di linguaggio
che abbiamo acquisito nei decenni passati.
Questa è un'immagine simulata di quello
che una persona avrebbe potuto vedere
se si fosse trovata a piccola distanza
dalla coppia di buchi neri
che stavano facendo
l'ultimo giro di danza.
Quello che vedete è un campo stellato
dietro i buchi neri.
Perché il campo stellato si muove,
si agita, seguendo il moto dei buchi neri?
Essenzialmente perché la gravità
piega le traiettorie della luce
che vengono dalle stelle,
che sono in realtà fisse, ferme,
dietro questi due buchi neri.
Questo è un evento molto importante.
Ovviamente è il coronamento
di un sacco di lavoro,
ma è soprattutto l'alba
di una nuova esplorazione dell'Universo,
è qualcosa di molto importante.
Dal punto di vista
della nostra sete di conoscenza,
è effettivamente
un passaggio importante
per capire meglio cos'è la gravità,
cos'è lo spazio, cos'è il tempo.
Potrebbe essere una chiave per quella
che alcuni chiamano "La teoria del tutto".
Ma, soprattutto, io penso
che abbiamo creato,
usando una metafora
degli speech precedenti
un nuovo campo-base
da cui partire con un'esplorazione
su scienza e tecnologia,
che non possiamo neanche immaginare.
Io oggi non sono abbastanza saggio
per poter intuire che tipo di svolte
e di applicazioni in scienza e tecnologia
potranno nascere da questa cosa,
nella mia generazione.
Forse la mia generazione
non vedrà il vero frutto di questo lavoro.
Ma è per questo che noi lavoriamo:
non per noi, per le generazioni future.
È questo il messaggio
che dobbiamo dare come scienziati.
Quindi cose che adesso sono patrimonio
della fantascienza e dell'immaginazione,
in futuro potrebbero essere
effettivamente qualcosa di verificabile,
qualcosa di utilizzabile.
Un futuro che potrebbe essere lontano.
Grazie.
(Applausi)